ดูบอล
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ขยับขยับเลยนะได้ค่ะโอเครูเหรอวันนี้วัน
นี้วันอะไรคะอ๋อวันจันทร์ค่ะเก่งมากเลย
วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิง
23 ค่ะค่ะวันที่ 23 เดือนอะไรคะ
ดีเดือน
พฤษภาคม
เดือนพฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะดีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ค่ะ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ค่ะอ่ะพี่นัทจะงงนะสลับกันถามนะคะ
วันนี้ครูเอ็มเปลี่ยนที่แท็กชั่นมากไม่
ได้มันโยกได้ค่ะคุยเบาๆนะคะแล้วตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะครูเอ๋เวลาบ่าย 3 โมง 3  3
นาทีค่ะโหบ่าย
15:30 นได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะ 15:30 นนะคะสั่ง
ก็
เป็นเวลากลางวันค่ะเอา 3 โมงครึ่งแล้ว
ครูเอ๋วันนี้ครูหญิง
มีคำถามมีคำถามอ๋อมีคำถามถามถามใครคะถาม
ครูเอ๋ถามครูเอ๋ถามนักเรียน
ถ้านัดทำทุเรศถามครูเอ๋ค่ะทำ Today
แต่ว่าถามว่าอ่าได้ครูเอคะคำถามแรกอีก
1 วัน 1 วันเนี่ยมีกี่ชั่วโมง 1 วันนะคะ
คู๋คิดก่อนนะคะ
2  34  5
6  7  8  9  10  11
11  12  13  14  15  16
17  18  19  20  21  22  23  24 ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงนักเรียนนอนหลับแล้ว
ไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนก็ฟังไงนับเลข 1 วันมี
24 ชั่วโมงค่ะคำถามต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋เดี๋ยว
ผู้หญิง - ตอนนี้ก่อนนะคะได้ค่ะ 1 วัน
เนี่ยจะมีอ้าวลบผิดมี 24 ชั่วโมงค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยนอนแม่กูเองมีเตียงนอนเนี่ยนะ
คะแล้วก็คู๋คู๋นอนกี่ชั่วโมง
นอนกี่ชั่วโมงหรอคู๋นอนประมาณ 1:00 น 2:00
นบางวันตีหนึ่งบางวัน 2:00 น
ก็ 3  4  5  6 นอนประมาณนะคะประมาณ 4
ชั่วโมงครึ่ง
พรประมาณ 4 ชั่วโมงครึ่งค่ะอ่ะแล้วก็นอน 4
ชั่วโมงครึ่งทำงานมากๆใช่ไหมคะผู้หญิงใช่
ค่ะคุณก็จะถามว่าแล้วถ้าครูเอ๋เนี่ยนอนไป
สิ 1 ชั่วโมงครึ่งค่ะมันยังมีเวลาเหลือ
19 ชั่วโมงครึ่งใช่ 19 ชั่วโมงครึ่งครู
เอ๋กินกี่ชั่วโมง
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงทางชินใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ทำอาหาร
นะคะเออ
หรอคะกิน
กิน 1 ครั้งก็ประมาณ 10 นาที
10  10  10 กิน 1 วันน่ะใช้เวลากินอาหาร
ประมาณ
สามมื้อนะสามมื้อนะประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมง
เนี่ยใช้เวลากินประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงนั้นครู
เอ๋ทำอาหารด้วยอะทำอาหารอ่ะ PS ทำอาหาร
ใช้ทำการกี่ชั่วโมงทำอาหารตอนเช้า
รวมยังไม่รวมล้างใช่ไหมคะลองไปเลยก็ได้
ค่ะอยู่ในห้องครัวทำอาหารล้างจานล้างผัก
เนาะล้านแครอทล้างบล็อคเคอรี่ล้างผัดก็
นึกๆประมาณ 3 ชั่วโมง
3 ชั่วโมงถึง 4 ชั่วโมงค่ะค่ะ 3-4
ชั่วโมง
เกรซทำงานทำงานน้องมีคอมพิวเตอร์
กี่ชั่วโมงทำงานนะถูกสอนใช่ไหมค่ะสอนด้วย
อัดวีดีโอหรือวัดเตรียมหา topic คิด topic
ด้วยก็ 1  2  3  4
หัวหน้าอ่ะถ้ามีสอนอัดวีดีโอก็ 5-6
ชั่วโมงอ่ะผู้หญิงให้ 6 ชั่วโมงดีกว่าอ่า
ค่าถึง 6 ชั่วโมง 8 เตรียม topic อ่ะตัด
วีดีโอ
อ่าน Story สำหรับพูดอีกประมาณ 4  3  4
ชั่วโมงงั้นครูเอกก็ทำงานประมาณ 10
ชั่วโมงค่ะประมาณ 10 ชั่วโมงอันเดียวคะ
วิ่งบวกก่อนนะคะนอนบวกกินบวกทำอาหารบวกทำ
งาน 10
45 น
19  19 ชั่วโมงครึ่ง
ก็เหลือเวลาไหมคะเหลือค่ะครูเอ๋นี้ทั้ง
หมด
19 ชั่วโมงครึ่งค่ะอ่ะแต่กูเห็นเหลือ
เวลายี่สิบสี่ลบ 19 ชั่วโมงครึ่งเวรเหลือ
กี่ชั่วโมงคะเหลือ
4 ชั่วโมงครึ่งไหม
3 ชั่วโมงครึ่งไม่ผู้หญิงเอา 3 ชั่วโมง
ครึ่ง
ตกเลขนักเรียนอ้าว 3 ชั่วโมงครึ่งนาๆครู
เอ๋หรือ
โอเคมีมีอาบน้ำใช่ไหม
อาบน้ำอาบน้ำ
พูดเอ๋อาบน้ำแปรงฟันเข้าห้องน้ำ Witch
อาบน้ำเนี่ยนะคะ
ใช้เวลาทั้งหมด 1 วันเนี่ยกี่ชั่วโมงอ่ะ
ซักผ้าด้วยเนาะซักผ้ารวมในทำงานโอเคซักคะ
รวมที่ทำงานอ่ะอาบน้ำอาบน้ำแปรงฟันประมาณ
30 น
re30 นะ 1 วันนะคู๋
เช้าเย็นเราพูดเอ๋น้อยหรอไม่เห็นว่ากู
หญิงนะมามันดิบนานภีร์
คิดถึงฝานะคะขึ้นน้ำนานอาบน้ำเร็ว
อา 30 นาทีงั้นก็เป็นทั้งหมดก็ไม่ใช่ 19
ชั่วโมงแล้วเป็น 20 ชั่วโมง
4 ชั่วโมงโอเคแล้วพี่คิดถูกใช่ไหมกูเอก
เอกเก๋แม่แอ๊ดแมนติกไม่ดีนะ
4 อ้าครูเอ๋ก็ยังเหลือเวลา 1 วันเนี่ย 4
ชั่วโมงค่ะทำอะไรคะไม่ใช่นอนไม่ใช่กิน
ข้าวไม่ใช่ทำอาหารไม่ได้ทำงานไม่ได้อาบ
น้ำ 4 ชั่วโมง
4 ชั่วโมงเนี่ยก็และยังมีอีกประมาณ 30
นาทียี่สิบนาทียี่สิบแล้วพี่ลบตรงนี้เนาะ
อ่าผู้หญิงก็วันข้างบนต่อไปก็ได้เอาแบบ
เด่นไม่เป็นไรค่ะนี่กลับมาได้ค่ะกูอีกว่า
ใครก็ได้ค่ะ
ที่นี่อีก 20 นาทีน่ะครูเอกก็จะมีอันนี้
ค่ะมีสายยาง
อาจ
จะก็มีต้นไม้
ผู้หญิงไม่แน่ใจเห็นไหมล่ะกูเองไม่เห็น
หรอผู้หญิงไม่เห็นเนี่ยแต่ไม่แน่ใจว่า
เวลาอัดออกมามันจะเห็นไหมอ๋ออ๋อโอเคคุย
อีกรอบให้คุยกับให้อ่ะอาจจะต้องย้ายปังมา
ตรงนี้ละกันนะคะ
เป๊ปสีเขียวเห็นไหมคะตัวนี้เหมือนกันค่ะ
เห็นตรงนั้นอ่ะเห็นกูเองมีต้นไม้
และ
ก็รดน้ำต้นไม้ขอกูเอกก็รดน้ำต้นไม้
ประมาณ
20 นาที
r20 นนะครูเอ๋ก็เหลือ
เหลือเวลาประมาณ 3 ชั่วโมง
40 นาที
ทำอะไรอยู่ 4 ซีรีย์ค่ะ
โอเคดูซีรีส์ 3 ชั่วโมง 40 นาทีเลยหรอคะ 1
วัน
อ่า
บางทีมากกว่าอ๋อบางวันงานงาน 6 ชั่วโมง
ถึง 8 ชั่วโมงก็บวกไปดูซีรีย์ค่ะงูครูเอ๋
ติด 4 รีดใช่ไหมคะต้องดูไม่มาดูแบบ 5 ไม่
ได้
โอ้ยเออไม่ดุ
ไม่ได้
อุ้ยแต่กูเอ๋ยังดีนะกูยังแบบดูซีรีส์
แต่ดูมากๆไม่ดีนะครูเอ๋ตาไม่โอเคนะคะใช่
ดูรถตาบวมตาใหญ่
ใช่ตาเนี่ยโหเจ็บเจ็บตา
แต่ครูเอ๋เนี่ยดูซีรีส์หนูซีรีย์ก็เป็น
โซเชียลมีเดียไหมก็ก็เป็นนะเอาเป็นน้ำ
เป็นคู๋ชอบดูใช่มั้ยดูดูซีรีส์เอาจริงๆ
บางทีก็ไม่ใช่ดูซีรีส์อย่างเดียวคุยอิ๋ง
อะไรคะดู YouTube  are
you เสือนดู YouTube  YouTube อุ้ยดี
มั้ยไม่เป็นในเป็น YouTube เป็น
โซเชียลมีเดียดูดูลายเอาโอ้ย LINE พี่มง
ใช่ไหมคะ
นี่ๆนี่ไงนี่ไงนี่ไง
อะไรคะนี้นี่ไงคะครูเอ๋ไงครูเอ๋มีเอ่อไม่
ดูดูดูลายสักผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไม่ถังขยะ
ใช่ค่ะก็มีถังขยะอันนี้อันนี้นี้เป็นถัง
ขยะไงก็ครูเอ๋เนี่ยดูผู้หญิงต้องขยับ
นิดนึงนะคะอ๋อใช่เวลาเราทิ้งไปใช่มะถึง
ไร่เหมือนๆทิ้งเวลาเลยนักเรียนมีผู้หญิง
รู้ไหมวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์นะคะนักเรียนค่ะ
อุ้ยทำไมคุยกันไม่ออกอ่ะเมื่อวันเสาร์อะ
พี่จะให้ก็ได้ค่ะตัวเองวันเสาร์เนี่ยวัน
เสาร์
เป็นวันหยุด
วันหยุดคือครูเอ๋น่ะไม่ทำงานวันเสาร์ไม่
ทำงานไม่ค่อยบอกคู๋วันเสาร์มีคลัชโอเคไว้
คุยไม่ทำงานวันเสาร์
ไม่ต้องงานครูเอ๋พยายามออกไปข้างนอกเพราะ
ว่าถ้าวันเสาร์ไม่ทำงานอยู่ที่บ้านนะครู
หญิงนี่เลยค่ะที่ครูหญิงเห็นไหมค่ะ
Facebook อ่ะ youtube ไม่รู้เห็นหรือ
เปล่าอ่าเลยค่ะผู้หญิงขยับนะ Siri เออเออ
นี่ไง
อะไรเนี่ย
อันนี้มันคืออะไรคะผู้หญิงเอ้าอันนี้ไงก็
ครูเอ๋ถ้า 1 วันเนี่ยอย่างครูเอ๋ดูซีรีย์
ขอดู YouTube แต่ครูหยีอย่างเงี้ยอะ 1
วันเนี่ยโอ้โหดู Facebook ดู YouTube
เช็ครายเหมือนกันผู้หญิงดูซีรีย์แล้วก็ก็
ดู Facebook ด้วยแล้วก็หนูลายด้วยแล้วก็
ดู YouTube ด้วยกูอันนี้ไม่ได้นะครูเอ๋
เขาบอกว่าอะไรเราเนี่ยอาจจะท้อชอบใช้เวลา
เนี่ย 1 วันเนี่ยโซเชียลมีเดีย Social
Media  Social  Media ไม่ได้อัดทำไมไม่
ได้
ไม่ดีค่ะ
ไม่ดีตาเจ็บแล้วก็โซเชียลมีเดียแหละนั่ง
แล้วก็มองก็เล่นเล่นๆเนี่ยไม่ดีกับเราใช่
ๆขอขอขอเจ็บแล้วนักเรียนก็ดูเราที่
YouTube นะอันนี้ดีขอฟังภาษาไทยแท้ครู
หญิงครูเอ๋เนี่ยดู Social  Media อ่ะกู
เอนดูที่ดีๆอ๋อไม่ถ้าครูเอ๋เอ๋ดู Social
Media  1 ชั่วโมงหรือ 2 ชั่วโมงต่อวัน
ขณะนี้โอเคเหมือนนักเรียน 4 ชั่วโมงไม่
ได้ล่ะคะแกะ 4 ชั่วโมง 4 ชั่วโมง
4 ชั่วโมงครูเอ๋ดูซีรีส์ด้วยไงซีรีย์ก็
โอเคนะอ้าวมึงดูซีรีส์แต่กูเอกก็เปิดฟัง
เพลง
อันนั้นได้ค่ะดูซีรีย์แล้วก็มี YouTube
เปิดเพลงเรายังล่าดูซีรีส์อันนี้โอเคโอเค
ๆไม่ๆๆเหมือนครูหญิงไงครูหญิงเนี่ยดู
YouTube ขอดู YouTube ใช่ไหมคะดู YouTube
แล้วโทรศัพท์ก็เอ๋อ Facebook อุ้ยมีใครกด
ไลค์ Facebook ไม่ได้นะเช็ค Facebook
แล้วก็กดไลค์กดไลค์กดไลค์มึงกูอันนี้ไม่
ดีไงคอมีนิ้วอ๋ออ๋อไม่ได้แต่ครูเอกก็ทำ
เหมือนครูหญิงค่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดไม่ได้แล้วทุกวันทุกวัน
ทุกวันเนี่ยตื่นนอนมาหยิบโทรศัพท์แล้วก็
เช็คโซเชียลนี่ Facebook โอ้วอันนี้ไม่
ได้นะกูเอ๋เราต้องแบบเราต้องเลิกเราต้อง
หยุดหยุดราคาใส่ค่ะหยุดเล่นโซเชียลมีเดีย
อาจจะช้าจาก 7 วัน 7 วัน
7 วันเนี่ยหยุดหยุดเล่นโซเชียลมีเดีย
อย่าหยุด 7 วันหยุดเจ็บมังกรยุคถึง
ผู้หญิงคู๋ว่าหยุดนะหยุดแบบว่า 1 วัน
เนี่ย
1 วันน่ะใช่ไหมคะ 1 วัน
1 วันเนี่ยเคยเขียนไม่สวยแหละกู M
เปลี่ยนห้องแล้วเขียนไม่ค่อยได้ 1 วัน
จาก du  du  du  du
เฟชบุ๊คบ่อยๆนะค่ะก็เปลี่ยนเป็นหนึ่งวัน
ดูหนึ่งครั้ง
หนึ่งครั้งกรอาจจาก 1 วันดูสิบครั้งก็
เปลี่ยนดู 1 ครั้งตอนนี้ครูเอกก็ดูหนึ่ง
ครั้ง
น้อริ้วแต่ว่าไม่ได้ไงกูเอ๋ผู้หญิงอ่ะ
เวลาได้ยินเสียง
[เพลง]
มันก็
ผู้ใช้ส่งต่อมาก็ปิดเสียงสิคะชายใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงต้องปิดเสียงก่อนใช่มั้ยคู๋มี
โทรศัพท์แล้วผู้หญิงก็ต้องปิดเสียงวิ่ง
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงปิดวายฟายก่อนนะคะเดี๋ยว
เน็ตที่นี่ไม่ดีฮ่าๆๆ
ผู้หญิงเมื่อก่อนน่ะตอนคู๋มีลายใหม่ๆโคกู
เอกเช็คไลน์ทุกวันเช็คจริงๆเสียเวลามากๆ
เช้าที่ทำงานทำอาหารไม่ได้ทำงานไม่ได้ถู
บ้านไม่ได้ดูดูๆจนเจ็บตา
คู่เอกก็เลยปิดเสียงไลน์แล้วก็ไม่อ่าน
ใช่ถ้ากูยังไม่ปิดเสียงหรือว่าปิดเสียง
ที่เป็นเสียงการแจ้งเตือนฉันให้พี่เอ๋
ปิ้งปิ้งวงอย่างเนี้ยบางทีผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ปิดเสียงแต่ว่า
เบอร์โทรศัพท์เนี่ยมันก็สั่นเออคุยกับ
ต้องปิดเหมือนครูเอ๋เลยค่ะคือปิดใช่ไหม
อ่าปิดแจ้งเตือนปิดแจ้งเตือนไปเลย
แล้วก็ 2 วันมา delete  delete กับ
ไม่อ่านแล้ว delete อย่างเดียวเลยยายค่ะ
แต่ถ้าบางคนแบบว่า
ยังรู้ไงบางคนเนี่ยปิดแจ้งเตือนแล้วครู
เอ๋แต่ก็ยังคิดแบบ
มีใครส่งหาเราไหมก็ยังหยิบโทรศัพท์มาดู
ก่อนดูปุ๊บหนูก็ดู Facebook ดู LINE นานๆ
ๆ
อันนั้นก็ต้องหยุดตัวเองค่ะคู่หญิงชายไม่
ดูนะคะแต่คู่หญิงอ่ะไม่ดูไลน์เลยอะไรค่ะ
ผู้หญิงสีถ้าไม่ดูลอยไม่ดู Facebook ไม่
ดูอะไรเลยนักเรียนครูเอ๋ส่ง Message หญิง
หญิงไม่ดู 1 วันสองวันคุยต้องโทรศัพท์ครู
หญิงดู
ข้อความที่ลายด้วยทรายค่ะเพราะว่าครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงหน้า 1 วันเนี่ยดูแต่เนี้ยค่ะ
YouTube
YouTube ดูอะไร
YouTube มันก็มีแบบอาจเป็นวีดีโออย่าง
เงี้ยดู Video  Lite  1 ชั่วโมง
หนึ่งสองชั่วโมง
สายโทรหาแต่บางคนเนี่ยไม่ได้ไงครูเอ๋เอ๋
ก็อาจจะต้องเนี่ยรูปนี้ที่ครูเอ๋ถามทำไม
ครูหญิงมีถังขยะค่ะ
เพราะว่าเวลาทั้งหมดใช่ไหมอยู่ที่อะไร
เนี่ยกูเองไม่รู้จักคุณครูเอ๋มีแค่
Facebook  YouTube
line แล้วก็เน็ตฟลิกซ์
หากูเอง
มี 4 อย่างอ๋ออ๋อครูหญิงเนี่ยมี Facebook
มี YouTube มี LINE มีทวิตเตอร์มี
อินสตาแกรมแต่ว่าติ๊กตอกอันนี้คือติดต่อ
ค่ะกูเอกติ๊กต๊อกเนี่ยไม่มีแล้วครูหญิง
เนี่ยลบเนี่ยกูเห็นลบขอใส่ถังขยะลบกูอยาก
รู้ไหมว่า
ตอบเนี่ยถ้าครูเอ๋สตาร์ทดูแล้วก็จะดูดูๆ
จุดไม่ได้หรอคะไม่ได้ค่ะก็จะหยุดโห 2
ชั่วโมงแล้วอ๋อโอเคไชโย
ครูเอ๋ไม่มีติ๊กต๊อกตายกูอ่ะจะมีติ๊กต๊อก
ดีแล้วค่ะเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนครูหญิงมี
ติ๊กต๊อก kuai ไม่มีติ๊กต่อกไม่มีอะไรนะ
สีชมพู
Instagram ไม่มีนกสีฟ้าขอทวิตเตอร์ไม่
รู้จัก
แต่ติ๊กต๊อกเนี่ยโตผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าถ้า
กูหญิงดูแล้วหยุดไม่ได้คุณก็ดู
ใช้เวลานาน
Six เอาติ๊กต่อก
ติ๊กต๊อก
ลบค่ะลบติ๊กตอกไปเลยแล้วอ่ะเอาติ๊กตอกลง
ถังขยะไปชายค่ะเอาติ๊กตอกลงแต่ว่า YouTube
ไม่เอา Facebook เก็บไว้ต่อลายเอาแป๊บนึง
นะคะไลน์เก็บไว้ไหมคะไลน์เก็บไว้เค้าทำไม
คะอ่ะจะไลน์บอกให้ทิ้ง LINE ด้วยหรอลาย
แบบไม่เอาไลน์จะไปนะคะนักเรียน
เกี่ยวกับอ้าย
เครียดไว้เก็บไว้
ผู้หญิงทิ้งติ๊กต๊อกอย่างเดียวอย่างเดียว
ค่ะลบทิ้งอย่างเดียวครูเหล่าจะครูเอ๋ไม่
มีทวิตเตอร์โคเอไม่เอาแต่ไม่เอา Instagram
ไม่อายลาย
ลายอ่ะครูเอ๋โอเคเพราะครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ดูอะไร
ครูเอ๋ดูแค่
เพื่อนส่งอะไรมาอ่าแล้วก็อ่านแล้วก็ ok
ส่งกลับเท่านั้นครูเอ๋ไม่เสียเวลากับลาย
ก็โอเค
สำหรับผู้ทำมิ่ง
ช้อปปิ้งที่ไลน์เหรอคะอ๋อไลน์แมนไลน์ฟ
อร์ดอะไรแนน YouTube ก็โอเคอันนี้ของครู
เอ๋ค่ะกูเอมี่ 3 อย่างค่ะ
ผู้หญิงลายลายคู๋ไม่เสียเวลามากๆมา 8 แปล
ว่าบางทีทักคุยคุยนานๆก็เสียเวลามาก
เหมือนกันตอนนี้ก็เอกก็ไม่ไม่ค่อยใช้ลาย
ชอบใช้ Line โทรศัพท์
โทรเลยฮัลโหลจะกินอะไรอะเขตจบมีใช่แต่ว่า
ถ้าบางคนแบบป้าหยุดไม่ได้ก็ลบทิ้งก็ได้
ค่ะจะได้ไหมเห็นชายไม่ปวดหัวพี่น้องแต่
ถ้า Facebook ตอนนี้คู่เอกก็น้อยลง
ใช่ผู้หญิงก็ 1 วันหนึ่งครั้งนะคะดูๆแล้ว
ก็ผู้หญิงเนี่ยอ่า
10 ชั่วโมง
มี YouTube นักเรียน
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงนอนกี่ชั่วโมงมีทรายก็เวลา
เวลาคิด topic ก็เหมือนครูเอ๋ฟังเพลงที่
YouTube ต่ออ๋อ
บางทีเราก็ดู YouTube แล้วก็อะไรนะดูที่
ดีๆใช่ไหมคะค่ะ
ก็ดูแล้วก็คิดเอง
อะไรอะไรเอามาพูดให้นักเรียนฟังนะคะบาย
ค่ะนอนแต่ถ้าบางคนไม่ได้ใช่ไหมอยากจะแบบ
หยุดโซเชียลมีเดียกว่าจะต้องลบทิ้งหรือ
ว่าแบบโอ้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงแต่ตอนนี้คุณไม่
มี Social  Media  100% เลยได้ไหมคะไม่
ได้ค่ะค่ะไม่ได้บ้างนักเรียนอาจจะมีเป็น
อีเมลพี่น้อง email  WhatsApp อะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยแต่คนไทยเนี่ยไลน์นะคะ LINE  24
ชั่วโมง Facebook ใช่ต่อคุยผู้หญิงเคยเคย
เห็นไปหาบอกว่าคนไทยเนี่ยน่าจะ
90%  Facebook นะเล่น Facebook มีตั้ง
แต่เด็กๆจนคนแก่ๆนะทุกคนมี Facebook ตอน
นี้ครูเอ๋นะดู Facebook นิดหน่อยผู้หญิง
บอกคนไทย 90 เปอร์เซ็นต์ชอบ Facebook
ทำไมค่ะ
คิดว่าน่าจะแชร์ได้แล้วก็อ่านอ่านได้แล้ว
ก็ถ่ายรูปโพสต์รูปได้นะคะคนไทยเนี่ยเด็ก
สมัยตั้งแต่อายุแบบสิบขวบจนถึงหาสมุดสัก
60 ใช่ไหมเอ่อเขาเรียกอะไรค่ะ
แอพพลิเคชั่นที่คนไทยมีดีมากที่สุดกอล์ฟ
เล่นมากที่สุดก็คือ Facebook ใช้ค่ะแล้ว
ก็ถ้าเป็น Twitter  Instagram เนี่ยหน่อย
ก่อนกูเอกก็ Facebook มากๆผู้หญิงตอนนี้
น้อยลงน้อยลงน้อยลงน้อยลงอาดู Facebook
น้อยลง
ใส่แต่คนไทยมี Me  and เขาเป็น Facebook
มากที่สุดค่ะมากกว่าลายมากว่าทวิตเตอร์
มากกว่า Instagram ขาคนไทยกิน Facebook
นะคะทุกอย่าง Facebook ใช่ไหมค่ะแต่เขา
ว่ามันมีอีกนะครูเอ๋ถ้าครูเอ๋ป่ะล่ะไม่
อยากลบแอปจะอยากหยุดหยุดโซเชียลมีเดียชัด
ก่อนพัก 1 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมง
นิอันนี้ไม่ได้นะคะอันนี้อ้างอิงเตอ net
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ฮ่าๆทำงานปิดไม่ได้ก็ปิดที่
โทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมที่โทรศัพท์เนี่ยปิด
อินเตอร์เน็ตที่โทรศัพท์ได้อย่างผู้หญิง
ไม่ใช่มั้ยก็ไปที่ที่นี่นะคะแล้วก็เปิด
เป็นหนี้แอร์เพลนโหมดอ้าอันนี้มันก็จะปิด
หมดเลยนะโซเชียล internet  WiFi อันนี้ก็
ปิดอาจจะเหมือนคู่เอ๋บอกมั๊ยคะปิด
ประมาณ 2 ชั่วโมง
2 ชั่วโมงปิดไปก่อนคู่ f ปิด 4 ชั่วโมง
ครึ่งค่ะคู่หญิงไหมไม่ปิด 4 ชั่วโมงครึ่ง
นอนใช่ไหมคะไอ้ผู้หญิงรู้ค่ะ
หนูไปปิดตอนนี้อีก 4 ชั่วโมงครึ่ง
ดีใช่เพราะว่าครูเอ๋บางคนน่ะบางคนอันนี้
อันนี้ไม่ดีเลยนะคะเล่นโทรศัพท์ก่อนนอน
นอนแล้วก็เล่นดอกรักจะนอนแล้วใช่ไหมอย่าง
อ่ะครูหญิงนอน 10:00 น
10:00 นเนี่ยนอนเนาะประมาณ
9:00 นกับผู้หญิงอยู่ที่นี่นอนบนเตียง
แล้วก็มีโทรศัพท์แล้วก็เล่นโทรศัพท์เล่น
เล่นแล้วก็หลับอันนี้อันตรายครูหญิงทำไม
เพราะว่าโทรศัพท์ยังอยู่นะมันมีแอร์มัน
ลื่น
คือเนี่ยบางทีมันเข้าหัวเข้าตัว
ปืน
ใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋นั่นแหละค่ะก็เลยแบบบางคน
เล่นก่อนนอนจะนอนก็เล่นใช่ไหมบางคนก็ปิด
ไฟ
มีอื้อเนี่ยหน้าทั้งหมดเป็นสีดำฮือ
สีดำช่วยไหมคะมือ
ๆ
ค้างหมด
แล้วเปิดโทรศัพท์
สว่าง
ตาก็ไม่โอเคอันนี้มันมืดหรือมันสกปรกคะ
ผู้หญิงอีก
นักเรียนมืดนักเตะอันนี้ดีกว่าไม่ง่าย
กว่าไม่คุยอีกน่าเบื่อพูดใช่ไหมมืดแล้ว
คุณก็เล่นโทรศัพท์
แล้วก็หลับแล้วก็โทรศัพท์อยู่ที่นี่ครู
เอกก็บอกไม่ดี
ตาก็ไม่ดีสมองก็ไม่โอเคที่นี่ก็จะคิด
internet  Social  Media มากับ
มันจะเร็วเร็วๆเคมันจะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะครู
หญิงคู๋ได้ยินนะได้ยินคลื่นน่ะถ้าหลับใช่
ไหมวันนี้หลับละหลับโทรศัพท์ที่มันก็ยัง
มีคื่นไช่มันก็จะเข้าสมองนี่ไฟสายแล้วก็
ไม่ไม่ใช่แค่ขึ้นนะกูเอ๋เวลาเราดู
โทรศัพท์อ่ะอีกโซเชียลมีเดียมันเร็วค่ะ
เวลาเราดูมันจะเร็วๆ
สมองเวลาเรานอนเราจะหลับไม่ร้อย
เปอร์เซนต์หมอมันก็จะก็ไม่ดีใช่เพราะที่
นี่มันสมองมายังคิดว่าโซเชียลมีเดียมัน
เร็วแล้วจะเหมือนตาเราเห็นอะไรบอกสุด
ฝึกเร็วๆมันทำให้เราหลับแต่ไม่ร้อย
เปอร์เซ็นต์ไม่น่าฟังแล้วน่ากลัวจะไม่ใช่
ทำให้เราอ่ะช่วงเวลาเรานอนเราคิดเรานอน
แต่ที่นี่สมองเราเนี่ยไม่นอน
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงแล้วถ้าเขาเล่นโทรศัพท์แต่
เขาไม่ดูไม่ได้ดูอ่ะติ๊กต๊อกไม่แต่ดู
YouTube ในโทรศัพท์แล้วก็เป็นนะ
โมโมตะพระสวดมนต์โอเคไหมล่ะอันนี้มีสั่ง
ใช่ไหมคะฟังๆฟังก็ไม่เป็นไรอันนี้โอเค
เพราะว่าฟังเหมือนคุณพ่อคุณแม่บอกพูดแล้ว
ลูกก็หลับไปก็จะไม่เหมือนกันแต่ถ้าดูขาว
เร็วๆเนี่ยไม่ดีค่ะ
แบบฟันจริงๆก็ไม่ดีค่ะนะคะผู้หญิงคือฟัง
แล้วก็ต้องปิดโทรศัพท์แล้วไปข้างนอกแล้ว
ก็นอนเพราะว่าถ้าไม่ปิดคลื่นโทรศัพท์ก็
ยังมานะคืนนี้มาดีไม่ดีไม่ดีสายค่ะแต่ว่า
มันแต่เราหลับ
100% โอเคก็ตาเราไม่ได้ดูสมองเราก็จะ
หลับคนคือ
100% ไงจ่ายอันนี้ไม่ดีนะหยุดนะหยุดใช่
ไหมเราต้องไม่เล่น Social  Media เยอะๆ
YouTube โอเคนะคะ YouTube โอเคมีเวลา
อะไรมีต้องใช้เวลา 1 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมง
แล้วก็พ่อนะฮะไม่เอาหยุดฟังภาษาไทย 2
ชั่วโมง 3 ชั่วโมงโอเคไหม
ก็ 3 ชั่วโมงก็หยุดหยุดด้วยนะคะ R ถ้าไม่
หยุดก็เหนื่อยอ่ะหยุดค่อยไปฟังใหม่นะคะๆ
ค่ะเนาะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วหรอ
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบาย